we've returned the jungles of southern
beliefs where the Jaguar rules the night
once the ancient Maya's believed that
stars were spots on a big cats coat at
one with the evening sky as its stalked
through the shadows tonight this fierce
proud hunter is stalking a young
crocodile
[Music]
the Jaguar is the largest and most
powerful cat in the Western Hemisphere
and third-largest overall only lions and
tigers are bigger Jaguars are
comfortable in the water in fact they're
one of the few cats who enjoy water the
average male Jaguar weighs 200 pounds
and lives 12 to 15 years in the wild
it's an endangered species mainly
because of the skin trade and habitat
destruction this Jaguar is displaying a
lethal self-confidence as it fishes for
croc
not much question who's gonna win this
battle time to close the deal
it's not hard to see how the Jaguar got
its name
it's from the Guarani Indian word yeah
Guara
meaning beast that captures its prey in
a single bound